blockers very funny movie but there's
something that I don't even know existed
there's a scene where characters are
engaged in something I'm told it's
called butt chuggin yep yeah and I I had
not heard of this you never heard of
butt chugging
no you heard about oh of course I heard
a bunch I get around yeah we're from
Chicago
[Applause]
what about chugging is it's you know how
you chug a beer normally sure you do
with your butt but how does it what do
you mean how does that even work you
take a funnel yeah and you you shove it
up your ass yeah and you pour beers in
it and it's supposed to get you drunker
faster and you know it's it's something
that it's like a tide pod thing where I
think a couple people did it but we're
making it big and we do the gratulations
thank you yeah thank you
one day that scene will be and then here
is your Nobel Prize thank you thank you
so much
but you had to really do this I didn't
do what John Cena did it and he did it
for real it wasn't like it there's never
been a time for CGI no it's when you
it's when during the but chug this is
practical that man is committed to his
craft and he stuck it yeah in her in and
around his but night and I was just
assisting yeah right yeah he was like
Karl Malone I was like John Stockton
Leslie man was like Jeff hornacek
yeah do you guys like Jeff hornacek you
know you should clear these references
you should clear these references with
me before you come out and I will tell
you
you